اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير نحييكم الى
بانوراما كالعاده اليوم كذلك سنناقش فيها
ونحاور ضيوفنا في خصوص التقارب الايراني
السعودي عبر محاور مختلفه طيله هذا
الاسبوع بالنسبه لهذا المساء هذه هي
العناوين
وساطه بيكين بين الرياض وطهران هل ينجح
التنين فيما فشلت فيه واشنطن ولماذا تقبل
السعوديه بالوسط الصيني
هل سيرى البيت الابيض هذا الاتفاق فرصه
ذهبيه لتخفيض التوتر في الشرق الاوسط ام
سيعتبرها فتحا صينيا لمنطقه طالما كانت
تصنف على انها حليف للولايات المتحده
وفي المحور الثالث من هذا النقاش وساطت
بكين هل تبشر بميلاد القرن الصيني كما
تكون نيويورك تايمس
ونحييكم الى التفاصيل بمبادره من الرئيس
الصيني نجحت وساطه بيكين بين رياض وظهران
في التوصل لتوفيق او لتوقيع اتفاق لاعاده
العلاقات في العاشر من مارس الجاري بين
بلدين ورجاء الاعلان عن الاتفاق بعد
محادثات كانت غير معلنه مسبقا واستمرت
اربعه ايام في بكين بين كبار مسؤولي الامن
من البلدين ورغم ان العراق وسلطنه عمان
كان سبقين للتوسط بين السعوديه وايران الا
ان اتفاق انهاء القطيع الدبلوماسيه بين
البلدين كان على يد الصين وفي الخطوات
التمهيديه لمسعها سلكت الصين سلوكا
متوازنا بين الخليج وايران وفقا لموقع
عربي ويسعى الاتفاق الى فتح المجال لشراكه
اوسع في مجله متعدده والى تفعيل اتفاقيه
التعاون الامني بين البلدين والموقعه سنه
2001 من جهته اكد وزير الخارجيه السعودي
فيصل بن فرحان للشرق الاوسط ان رياض وهران
تستعدان الاستئناف العلاقات الدبلوماسيه
خلال الشهرين المقبلين ومن الطبعين
مستقبلا ان يتم تبادل الزيارات وفق قوله
مصالح الصين في المنطقه تربط الصين شراكه
استراتيجيه شامله مع السعوديه وايران
طموح صيني بلعب دور اكبر في المنطقه
الاستحواذ على ادوار كانت تلعبها دول اخرى
كاميركا تبعات الحرب الاوكرانيه
الحاجه الصينيه المتزايده الى الطاقه
تستورد الصين 70% من استهلاكها النفطي من
الخليج
تامين ممرات الطاقه
تهدف الصين لشرق اوسط اكثر استقرارا لاجل
استثماراتها
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من الرياضه
الدكتور عبد العزيز بن صقر رئيس مركز
الخليج للابحاث من نيويورك طوني بدران
الباحث في مركز الدفاع عن الديمقراطيات
ومن بكين صحفي تشاو تشينجون
عبر زوم الصحفيه الصينيه طبعا اهلا بكم
ضيوفي الكرام واسمحوا لي ان نبقى دائما في
مناقشه مختلف المحاور طيله هذا الاسبوع في
بانوراما فيما يخص هذه الاتفاقيه
الايرانيه السعوديه واسمحوا لي ان ابدا من
الرياض معك دكتور عبد العزيز دكتور عبد
العزيز في الواقع البعض وصف ما حدث
بالاختراق الصيني يبقى السؤال لماذا وساطه
صينيه لماذا لا نتحدث عن وساطه امريكيه عن
وساطه روسيه خاصه مثلا بالنسبه لروسيا وان
علاقاتها جيده مع المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وعلاقاتها كذلك مع ايران اصبحت
اكثر متانه بعد الحرب الاوكرانيه لماذا
بالتحديد الصين التي دخلت بحسب قراءتك خط
الوساطه
اول مساء الخير
في كل مكان
في الحقيقه ان اختيار الصين له عده عوامل
اولا الصيني هي دوله عضو في مجلس الامن من
الصعوبه ان تقبل ايران بدول اوروبيه او
بامريكا ان تكون طرف وسيط بسبب الوضع
القائم فيما بينهم في الوقت الحاضر روسيا
ايضا هي تخوض حرب مع اوكرانيا فمن الصعب
ادخالها في موضوع مثل هذا ولذلك الصين
لمكانتها لقدرتها لعلاقتها المتميزه مع
الجانبين السعودي والايراني جعلها الخيار
الافضل النقطه الثانيه والمهمه ان الصين
تاريخيا كانت دائما تقول انها تريد ان
تبقي مسافه متوازيه ولكن في القمه القمه
التي تمت في الرياض في شهر ديسمبر بمشاركه
الرئيس الصيني وهي قمه سعوديه خليجيه
عربيه
كان هنالك في البيان الختامي اشاره الى
اهميه ان ايران بالنسبه لايران ان يكون
تراعي الظروف الامنيه في المنطقه وان تكون
عنصر فاعل في استتاب الامن والاستقرار هذا
الموضوع ازعج ربما ايران في حينه لذلك
استدعت السفير الايراني في طهران هذا
الاستدعاء نتج عنه بعد ذلك الزياره للرئيس
الايراني الى الصين ويبدو تمت المفاهمه
هنالك خلال زياره الرئيس الصيني لانه اذا
الصين هي اكبر مشتري للطاقه من ايران ولها
علاقه قويه وتساندها في كثير من قضاياها
وقفت معها في الامم المتحده في كثير من
قضايا وايضا استعدت الصين لاستثمارات ضخمه
مستقبليه كبيره على المدى العشرين سنه
القادمه بمبلغ 400 مليون دولار فهذا يجعل
الصين مكانه خاصه تقدرها ايران وايضا
مكانه الصين خاصه المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
وقويه سواء تاريخيا في العديد من المواقف
او ايضا من ناحيه العلاقه الاقتصاديه
المملكه لوحدها اكثر من 80 مليون دولار
على قتل اقتصاديه مع الصين وهذا حجم كبير
اذا قرن باجمال حجم التجاره الصينيه مع
الدول العربيه التي يبلغ اكثر من 300
وعشرين مليون دولار لكل هذه الاسباب يعني
الصين كانت
الاختيار الافضل والاميز وفي المقابل
استاذ تشاو ما مصلحه الصين في
خاصه وان الصين لديها مصالح في اسيا لديها
مصالح في المحيطين الهادي والهندي هناك
يعني بعض الاشكالات التي لا زالت ابوابها
مفتوحه انت تتجه نحو هذه المنطقه نحو
الشرق الاوسط نحو الخليج العربي ما الذي
يعني ذلك
باعتبارها اكبر دوله التجاريه في العالم
وتامل في تعزيز تنميه السلميه
للمجتمع الدولي وكما تعمل الصين في قرض في
خرج بيئه تنميه سلميه من خلال نفوذها
المتزايد تدريجيا واكبر
ان اكبر شركاء التجاريين
للمملكه العربيه السعوديه
تعاون المواجعه بين الصين وهاتين ادارتين
طويله جدا وفي الوقت نفسه تعتبر بطاقه
الشرق الاوسط شرق الاوسط مهمه جدا لتدوير
المبادره الحزام وطريق الصينيه
معروف هناك رابط
قوي بين المبادره خزام طريق ورؤيه
عمل فين و30 للسعوديه فاعتقد ان هناك
لدي لديها سين مسارقا مشتركا مشتركه كبيره
في في شرك الاوسات مع مع دول مع دول في
هذه المنهاجات نعم يعني نبقى دائما في
اطار الشراكه الاقتصاديه وكذلك محاوله
تثبيت حاله الامن في هذه المنطقه ولكن
دكتور ماتوني لتحقيق ذلك يقول البعض بان
الصين كانها قلبت الطاوله على دبلوماسيه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هل يصح هذا
القول ام ان هناك مبالغه في ذلك
مساء الخير انا اعتقد انه في نوع من
المبالغه انما ليس يعني ليست مبالغه كبيره
بمعنى انه هناك حدث تاريخي طبعا بدخول
الصين بهذه المنطقه بهذه الطريقه انما
ليست هي الصين التي قلبت معي هذا خيار في
النهايه يعود الى خيار المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
بتنويع خياراتها وبالتالي لارسال رساله
الى الولايات المتحده حول تنويع ليس حول
ترك الشراكه الاستراتيجيه مع الولايات
المتحده انما هناك نوع من شعور يعني
بالخيبه من خصوصا يعني مع الادارات
الديمقراطيه المتعاقبه مباراه اوباما
الان
يعني مما اثار هذا يعني هذه الحاجه الى
التنويع والتحويط اذا ما اردت انما يعني
من الناحيه الشراكه العسكريه والشراكه
الاستراتيجيه والاقتصاديه وحتى الثقافيه
يعني هي بتصور اعمق بكثير كانت ولا تزال
مع الولايات المتحده انما هذا قرار اتخذته
المملكه العربيه
لهذا السبب يعني برايي انا وهو نوع من
تحويض ولا سالتي يعني لماذا ليست روسيا
لان روسيه لا تستطيع القيام بهذا الدعوه
هناك فقط
الولايات المتحده والصين يعني هدول هم
الخيارين المتوافرات
والمملكه يعني
اخر قرار بها
هذه الرساله تحديدا الى الولايات المتحده
وخلق يعني نوع اذا بدك
من فتره اختبار
ويعني
تمرير للوقت اذا اذا اردنا يعني القول
لافهم منك استاذ توني من الذي بعث رساله
المملكه العربيه السعوديه بعثت برساله
لواشنطن او الصين بعثه رساله
لا المملكه العربيه السعوديه المملكه
العربيه هذا خيار المملكه العربيه
بالنهايه يعني بالذهاب الى الى الصين يعني
اذا المملكه العربيه لم ما ارادت انه تروح
تصير لانه بتصور حتى يعني دور او اذا بدك
هذه الهدنه او التقارب الدبلوماسي او
العوده بالاحرى يعني الى
العلاقات الطبيعيه الدبلوماسيه
التي كانت يعني كان في سفاره وكان في
قنصليات قبل ان يتم التعدي عليها في ايران
يعني كانت موجوده كانت العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه موجوده نوع من عوده هذا ليس
صلب يعني ليس الاساس برايك الاساس هو
الخيار المملكه بالذهاب الى الصين
يجب ان كذلك نفهم قراءه الدكتور عبد
العزيز فيما يخص هذا الموضوع دكتور بن صقر
هل تعتقد كظيفه بانه هناك عمليه اختبار من
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
لنوايا واشنطن الحقيقيه ام تعتقد كما يرى
مراقبون اخرون بان الموضوع
لا يرقى الى هذا الحد وبان المملكه بفكر
جديد بتطلعات جديده هي تقدم مصلحه الداخل
مصلحه المنطقه على هذه الحسابات كيف ترى
هذه القراءات المختلفه
اولا واشنطن لم تكن طرف وسيط بين المملكه
وايران واشنطن كانت تفاوض مع دول مجموعه
الخمسه في فيينا حول البرنامج النووي فمن
الصعب لدوله تفاوض في برنامج مع دول اخرى
ولذلك يعني كانت الاختيارات صعبه لما تنظر
للمجلس الامن لا فرنسا ولا بريطانيا ولا
المانيا ولا
امريكا يمكن اختيارها لانها هي تفاوض مع
ايران في مفاوضات البرنامج النووي
والمتعثره حاليا النقطه الثانيه لا يوجد
علاقات دبلوماسيه مباشره وقويه بين واشنطن
وامريكا في الخيار السعودي الامثل كان
وقبول الصين والصين طبعا
واشنطن وايران
فالخيار الامثل كان هو قبول الصين كوسيط
لكل النقاط المهمه التي يعني ذكرناها لكن
ايضا احنا يجب ان لا نضخم الموضوع لانه
يعني هنالك ثلاثه انواع الاعتراف الاعتراف
بالنظام
والعلاقه الدبلوماسيه الاعتراف بالدوله
والنظام موجود الدبلوماسيه كانت موجوده
لما سار الاعتداء على السفاره السعوديه
والقنصليه في يناير 2016 قررت المملكه ان
تسحب سفيرها وان تقطع العلاقه مع ايران
لانه هذا مخالف الاعراف الدوليه
والاتفاقيه فيينا التي تفرض على الدوله
توفير الحمايه اللازمه للمنشات
الدبلوماسيه
والموظفين الدبلوماسيين الامر الذي لم تقم
به ايران في المفاوضات الخمسه جولات
السابقه كان هنالك تركيز حول مدى قدره
ايران في توفير هذه الحمايه وهذا النوع من
الضمان بسبب لانه
في يعني بعد الحادثه تبع السفاره السعوديه
تم الاعتداء على سفارات اخرى
ودبلوماسيين اخرين فهذا طرح التساؤل المهم
هل هنالك قدره لدى النظام الايراني في بسط
نفوذه وسيطرته على المنشات
والمقرات الدبلوماسيه
وتوفير الحمايه وحمايتها هذا كان تساؤل
مهم
فيبدو انه هنالك مع الجولات الخمسه لانه
حتى في السابق الدول العراق
والسلطنه عمان مشكورين لعبوا دور في توفير
المناخ الملائم للحديث بين الطرفين
والمملكه لم تكن تعارض الحديث مع ايران
المملكه كانت تحفظها ان ايران تريد ان
تركز فقط على اعاده العلاقه الدبلوماسيه
في الوقت للمملكه تريد ان تنظر في مجمل
الامور الان العلاقه الدبلوماسيه تم
القرار باعاده فتحها والتواصل هذا سوف
يفتح المجال للحوار المباشر في كافه
القضايا مثل ما اليوم سموزي الخارجيه في
لقاءه مع الشرق الاوسط اوضح هذه النقطه
بشكل واضح
سلطنه عمان لكن البعض استوقفه الشكل كذلك
لان الصين لم تفعل سابقاتها او كسابقيها
من الوسطاء لم تمكن الاطراف من جو ملائم
للنقاش وانما كانت حاضره كذلك على الطاوله
كانت حاضره معهم والبعض اعتبرها كضامن ان
كان لك تعليق باختصار انت كرمت حول هذه
النقطه هل يمكن الصين ان لا تتوسط وان
تضمن يعني اكثر من ذلك
لا انا اعتقادي المفاوضات الخمسه السابقه
التي حصلت في بغداد وفي عمان
جهزت وحذرت لهذا اللقاء السادس انه النقاط
كلها كان متفق عليها هو كان منتظر ان يتم
لقاء وزيري الخارجيه يبدو ان التوجيه
السياسي صدر قبل ان يتم لقاء وزراء
الخارجيه الاثنين يكون هنالك اتفاق ينظم
نوعيه وطبيعه واسلوب العلاقه وذاك انتم في
تقريركم اوضحتم الاتفاقيات السابقه اوضحتم
احترام سياده البلدين اوضحتم الرغبه في
العيش بسلام في المنطقه اوضحتم قضايا
التنميه واهميتها فهذه كلها كانت اسس لانه
الصين تتمتع بالعلاقه الجيده هي تشجع
الاطراف ولكن مثل ما تفضل ضيفك الدكتور
توني انه لو لم يكن هنالك رغبه سعوديه في
قبول الصين للقيام بهذا الدور لما اتجهت
الى الصين هي قبلت بالعراق وقبلت بعمان في
في السابق
يعني منصه للحوار وتقريب وجهات النظر
ولقاء يعني يجمع الاطراف كح لكن حينما
انتقلنا للبعد الدولي اصبح هنالك ضروره في
وجود طرف على قال له تقدير من الطرفين لا
يمكن تقديم ضمانه معينه في الوقت الحاضر
انت تعيد العلاقه تفتح الحوار ولكن تتطلع
اليوم تصيح ايضا وزير خارجيه الايراني
يقول انه هو يرى انه هذا الاعاده العلاقه
سوف تساعد على حل الازمه اليمنيه وهذا
مؤشر كويس لكن ايضا
لبنان وسوريا والعراق صحيح هناك ملفات
اخرى عديده وهناك تفاصيل اخرى كثيره ولكن
تحدثت عن الضمانات حضرتك ترى بانه ليس
هناك
مش امكانيه ولكن ضمانات لا توضع في فترات
كهذه خلينا نسال بعض قليل ضيفنا من الصين
ان كان لها قراءه حول هذا الموضوع ولكن
تفضلوا بالبقاء معنا سنتوقف مع فاصل من
بعد سنستكمل هذا النقاش
وفي المحور الثاني من هذا النقاش
هل سيرى البيت الابيض هذا الاتفاق فرصه
ذهبيه لتخفيض التوتر في الشرق الاوسط ام
سيعتبرها فتحا صينيا لمنطقه طالما كانت
تصنف على انها حليف للولايات المتحده